[Musik]
Tatort Deutschland die crime Doku von
Bild
und herzlich willkommen zu einer neuen
Folge von Tatort Deutschland ich bin
Toni Haier und ich bin Mirko Kasimir
schön dass ihr wieder mit dabei seid
heute sprechen wir über einen Fall den
uns Hörer Torsten Ende Januar
vorgeschlagen hatte an der Stelle vielen
lieben Dank und liebe Grüße falls ihr
auch ein paar Fälle habt wo ihr sagt
dann müsst ihr unbedingt darüber
sprechen dann schickt ihr uns die ganz
einfach per Mail an podcast@bild.de oder
per Instagram die Links dazu haben wir
euch natürlich auch noch mal in die
schauen uns gepackt und ich weiß nicht
wie es Dir geht Liebe Toni aber wenn man
sich ein bisschen Einblick in unseren
heutigen Fall dann gibt es gleich
mehrere Gründe warum der sehr
eindrücklich ist ja und ich finde es
beängstigend wie jemand in so wenigen
Tagen gleich mehrere Morde begeht wie
unser heutiger Protagonist Steve right
meintest du das Mirko ja unter anderem
und natürlich auch dass dieser Steve
ride zwei seiner Opfer in der
Körperhaltung eines am Kreuzes abgelegt
hat ja auch das ist ein ziemlich
verstörendes Detail aber okay genug
vorweggenommen lass uns einfach loslegen
und der Anfang ist ebenso simpel wie
beängstigend im Jahr 2006 wurden im
englischen ipswitch im distric suffalk
nordöstlich von London bin kürzester
Zeit gleich fünf junge Frauen ermordet
es handelt sich um Gemma Adams 25
Tanja Nicole 19 Emily Editon 23
und erinnert Nikos 29 alle fünf waren
Prostituierte die sich mit käuflichen
Sex Geld für ihre Drogensucht
beschafften und alle fünf wurden
zwischen dem zweiten und dem 12 dezember
2006 gefunden
alle Opfer waren erwürgt worden keine
der Frauen wie es Kampfspuren oder
Spuren von sexuelle Missbrauch auf auf
eine weitere Gemeinsamkeit kommen wir
gleich wenn wir die Entdeckung der Toten
einzeln aufdröseln am 2 dezember 2006
entdeckt ein Fußgänger in der
wasserreichen Landschaft von hintischem
10 Autominuten westlich von ipswitch
eine Frauenleiche sie wird als die
25-Jährige Prostituierte Gemma Adams
identifiziert Gemma war seit dem 15
November vermisst worden Gemma kam aus
einer intakten bürgerlichen Familie aber
sie verlor wegen ihrer Drogensucht eine
Stelle bei einer Versicherung und
Prostituierte sich dann ihr Partner war
leider auch heroinabhängig nur ihre
Eltern wussten von all dem nichts nur
wenige Kilometer südlich davon an einem
Wassergraben in Kopf dogmilch wird sechs
Tage später Tanja Nicole gefunden 19
Jahre jung und ebenfalls drogenabhängige
Prostituierte
das letzte Lebenszeichen von ihr stammte
vom 30 Oktober tanja war zur Highschool
gegangen also dem englischen Gegenstück
des Gymnasiums verließ mit 16 dann aber
ihr Elternhaus um ihre Drogensucht zu
finanzieren arbeitete sie in einem
Massage-Salon wurde aber kurz darauf im
Rausch gefeiert ihre Mutter wusste nicht
dass sie anschaffte und dachte sie würde
in einer Bar oder bei einem Friseur
arbeiten die nächste Tote wird schon
zwei Tage später aufgefunden aber in
Nekton das ist ein Kampf 10 km östlich
von ICE
in einem Waldstück stößt ein
Spaziergänger auf die Leiche von Annelie
Elten bei der Obduktion stellt sich
heraus dass die 23-Jährige im dritten
Monat schwanger war Emily hatte einige
Umbrüche hinter sich ihre Mutter war mit
ihr 1992 nach der Trennung vom Vater
nach Zypern gezogen fünf Jahre später
kam sie zurück nach Switch nachdem ihr
Vater an Lungenkrebs starb nahm sie
Drogen in der Gegend um nackten werden
am 12 Dezember schließlich zwei weitere
Leichen gefunden es sind die von Paula
granell und ernährt Nicos Annett war
schon lange drogensüchtig sie wohnt in
einer Gemeinde Unterkunft ihren Sohn
hatte sie zur Pflege ihrer Mutter
überlassen
Paulas drei Kinder waren alle weggegeben
worden weil sie oft Droge war die
Auswertung von Spuren und die Leichen
schauen ergeben dass keine der Frauen
dort starb wo sie aufgefunden wurden
außerdem waren annely und Annett vom
Täter mit rechtwinklig abgespreizten
Armen wie bei einer Kreuzigung drapiert
worden als im Herbst die ersten Frauen
vermisst wurden wurde das nur in den
lokalen Medien vermeldet jetzt im
Dezember 2006 nach dem Fund von sechs
Frauenleichen ist die britische
Öffentlichkeit landesweit in Aufruhr
gesucht wird ab sofort der safox
strangler also auf Deutsch der Bürger
von suffalk die örtliche Polizei in
saarfog stellt schnell fest dass die
Fälle ganz offensichtlich
zusammengehören und fordert
Unterstützung aus London an schon nach
wenigen Tagen ermitteln 300 Beamte
später sind es 650 jeden Tag müssen mehr
als 400 Anrufe mit Hinweisen
entgegengenommen werden schon bald
sitzen die Polizisten an 10.000
telefonprotokollen durch die Lagerung
einiger der Leichen war die Sicherung
von DNA zunächst schwierig zum Beispiel
hatte Wasser viele Spuren abgespielt
außerdem war offenbar keiner der Frauen
vor ihrem Tod sexuelle Gewalt angetan
worden
es gab auch keine Spuren von Gegenwehr
während die umfangreichen Untersuchungen
andauern nimmt die Polizei aufgrund von
Hinweisen erstmals einen Verdächtigen
fest einen 37 Jahre alten Supermarkt
Angestellten aus der benachbarten
Hafenstadt Felixdorf aber er ist der
Falsche und dank sorgfältiger Arbeit
können eben doch DNA strenge gesichert
und sogar zugeordnet werden und die
führen zu einem anderen Mann zu einem
Mann namens Steve Wright
seine DNA befand sich in den
polizeiregistern seit er fünf Jahre
zuvor bei einem Diebstahl erwischt
worden war ride hatte umgerechnet 100 €
aus der Kasse einer Kneipe gestohlen in
der er damals arbeitete jetzt wird er
verdächtigt ein fünffacher Mörder zu
sein der Supermarkt Kassierer aus der
Nachbarstadt kommt wieder auf freien Fuß
erstmal gegen Kaution später ohne
Auflagen Steve Jared James right wird
als zweites von vier Kindern am 24 April
1958 in Norfolk geboren während rights
Vater Militärdienst leistet lebt die
Familie zeitweise in Malta und Singapur
die Eltern lassen sich später scheiden
Steve und seine Geschwister bleiben beim
Vater der mit seiner neuen Frau noch
zwei weitere Kinder bekommt
gleich nach der Schule an auf
Fährschiffen zu arbeiten im Laufe der
Jahre arbeitete er als Koch Stewart auf
der Queen Mary 2
Lastwagenfahrer Barmann und zum Schluss
als Gabelstaplerfahrer ride war zweimal
verheiratet aus der ersten Ehe gab es
einen Sohn ein weiteres Kind stammte aus
einer späteren Beziehung nach der
zweiten Ehe im Zeitraum der Morde hatte
er eine Beziehung zu Pamela Wright wobei
die Gleichheit des Namens hier Zufall
ist die beiden zogen 2004 zusammen in
ein Haus Steve right hat sich immer
wieder beim Glücksspiel verschuldet und
befand sich in einer Privatinsolvenz
zweimal hat er versucht sich das Leben
zu nehmen einmal mit Kohlenmonoxid
einmal mit Schlaftabletten auf den Fotos
von Steve right sieht man das unstädte
und all die Sorgen maximal im Blick
ansonsten wirkt er wieder typische n40er
aus der englischen Mittel- und
Unterschicht blond Lichter werdendes
Haar ein bisschen Übergewicht und
sportlich
das soll er also sein der Bürger von
safok aber bright streitet die Morde von
Anfang an ab dass er die Frauen als
Kunde getroffen hatte das gab er zu
alles andere wäre auch lächerlich
gewesen denn neben den DNA beweisen
trafen nach und nach auch immer mehr
Überwachungsbilder auf die ihn und sein
Auto in den fraglichen Nächten mit den
Prostituierten zeigten nach dem
schnellen Ermittlungserfolg Arbeiten
Polizei Staatsanwaltschaft und Gericht
sehr gründlich um einen Prozess
vorzubereiten
der beginnt schließlich am 16 januar
2008 die Aufmerksamkeit ist riesig vor
dem modernen hohen Gebäude stehen über
Wagen aller wichtigen Fernsehstationen
unter den Prozess Beobachtern im Innern
sind zahlreiche Angehörige der jungen
Opfer die Friedwald mittlerweile 49
Jahre alt gibt sich unbeteiligt und
streitet die Morde weiter ab
Staatsanwalt Peter ride zählt in der
Beweisaufnahme die DNA-Spuren auf die
videoüberwachungsaufnahmen und die
Details von den Fundorten der Leichen
der Angeklagte gibt zu mit vier der fünf
Frauen bezahlten einvernehmlichen Sex
gehabt zu haben nur einmal nämlich bei
Tanja Nicole sei es nicht dazu gekommen
die habe er ins Rotlichtviertel von IP
Switch zurückgefahren und überhaupt sagt
right im Prozess das ist für ihn schon
lange normal sei käuflichen Sex zu haben
LG seit 25 Jahren zu Prostituierten in
seiner Beziehung zu Pamela sei es oft so
gelaufen dass er sie erst zu ihrer
Arbeit im Callcenter vor und sich
anschließend im Rotlichtviertel eine
Prostituierte zum Sex aussuchte so sei
es auch im fraglichen Zeitraum 2006
gewesen
bright gibt zu ungefähr zu der Zeit als
Gemma Adams verschwand in seinem Autos
Sex mit ihr gehabt zu haben die anderen
habe er mit nach Hause genommen weil
seine Freundin Pamela keinen Geruch im
Bett bemerken sollte habe der Sex dort
auf Jacken auf dem Fußboden
stattgefunden die Morde müsse aber
jeweils jemand anderes begangen haben
sagt der kühlwirkende right im Prozess
der Staatsanwalt kontert überall an den
Frauen hätten sich Spuren von ihm und
dem Kofferraum seines Autos gefunden
selbst bei Tanja Nicoles obwohl die doch
im Wasser gelegen habe die Beweislast
ist einfach erdrückend trotzdem lässt
sich das Gericht Zeit arbeitet gründlich
zum Beispiel werden die Geschworenen zu
den Fundorten der Leichen gefahren um
sich selbst ein Bild zu machen nur das
Motiv des Mörders bleibt unklar weil er
dazu schweigt
warum mussten fünf junge Frauen in so
kurzer Zeit sterben warum drapierte er
zwei von ihnen später so wie bei einer
Kreuzigung am 21 februar 2008 verkündet
Richter gross das Urteil der Jury Steve
right muss lebenslang ins Gefängnis und
zwar ohne die Möglichkeit einer späteren
Bewährung die Morde seien mit vor
bedacht und Planung erfolgt bei der
Urteilsverkündung ertönen Laute jarufe
von den Zuschauerplätzen die
Familienangehörigen der Opfer halten
sich an den Händen er nennt Nicoles
Mutter bricht in Tränen aus und Paula
klanells Schwester und Mutter brechen
zusammen
Adams Vater Brian sagt ich bin sehr
erleichtert und freue mich für alle
Familien dass dies jetzt vorbei ist und
wir jetzt mit unserem Leben weitermachen
können
man kann die gründliche und schnelle
Arbeit der Polizei gar nicht genug loben
auch drei Geschwister des Mörders die
Frieds sind an diesem 21 februar im
Gerichtssaal sein Bruder Kiew empfindet
das Urteil als sehr hart es habe genug
Gründe für Zweifel an den tatabläufen
gegeben sein anderer Bruder David und
seine Schwester Jeannette verlassen das
Gerichtsgebäude unter Tränen und die
Vater Conrad hatte seinen Sohn vor dem
Urteil zu einem Geständnis aufgefordert
diesen Steve kenne ich nicht der Steve
den ich kenne würde mit mir Cricket
spielen und sich um unsere Hunde kümmern
aber keine Morde begehen er könnte nicht
mal einer Fliege etwas zu leidet tun
aber nun muss er aufstehen ist zugeben
und sich entschuldigen
rund um den Fall wurde damals übrigens
auch spekuliert dass die Fried schon
früher gemordet haben könnte zum
Beispiel verschwand 1986 eine 25-jährige
Frau die auf der Queen Mary arbeitete
wie Steve der dort ja als Stewart
angestellt war es wurden auch noch mal
ungeklärte Todesfälle in Ostengland aus
den Jahren 1992 bis 2000 daraufhin
abgeklopft ob ride auch hier als Täter
in Frage kommen könnte aber dies ließ
sich nicht erhärten oder gar beweisen
ich muss sagen was ich bei diesem Fall
besonders schrecklich finde hier sind
junge Frauen umgekommen die wirklich
Hilfe gebraucht hätten aber weil sie in
ihre Verzweiflung und gelten und
anschaffen gegangen sind passiert da
genau das Gegenteil und setzen sich
damit natürlich eine deutlich höheren
Gefahr aus dass ihnen Gewalt angetan
definitiv und ich glaube das gefährlich
ist auch
dass sie da so ausgeliefert sind also
ich meine es liegt auf der Hand das
perverse oder gewalttätige Männer dann
leichtes Spiel haben gerade bei
Prostitution auf der Straße wo es super
anonym ist also dass die Motive angeht
der Mann hat tendenziell hier die
Möglichkeit sich überlegen zu fühlen
also auch zu herrschen über Moral und
Tod so ein bisschen dieses Gott spielen
und die Frau die ist die böse dass die
[__] und wenn ich ihr was antun dann
liegt das nicht so schwer umso leichter
noch wenn die Prostituierte
drogensüchtig ist und ihre Familie nicht
mal weiß wo sie ist und das schlimme ist
oft bleibt den Frauen auf dem
Straßenstrich nichts anderes übrig als
gegenseitig auf sich aufzupassen aber
ich meine wenn eine in ein Auto steigt
und nie wieder auftaucht dann ist es eh
meistens schon zu spät und die anderen
was sollen sie denn machen ich meine das
Ansehen von ihnen ist sowieso
in den meisten Fällen sehr sehr niedrig
gesellschaftlich weil es einfach keinen
Job ist der gesellschaftlich akzeptiert
ist und auch immer noch stigmatisiert
wird und genau durch diese stickma dass
wir es nicht als ehrenwerten Beruf wie
jeden anderen ansehen sondern als was
ich sag jetzt mal was niedriggestellt
ist dadurch haben die Frauen es so viel
schwieriger und müssen auch teilweise
sich diesen Gefahren aussetzen und wir
sind eigentlich in der Pflicht viel mehr
dafür zu tun das kann doch nicht sein
dass diese Frauen um ihren Beruf
nachzugehen ihr Leben aufs Spiel setzen
müssen
Toni was du sagst spricht natürlich
dafür dass auch heute noch mehr für den
Schutz der Frauen in dieser Branche
getan werden muss und das verhindert
werden muss dass Frauen heute in diesen
ungeschützten und schwer
kontrollierbaren Bereich gedrängt werden
auch in Deutschland gibt es ja
Bemühungen Prostitution als einen
richtigen Beruf zu etablieren als
Sexarbeit mit Lohnsteuerkarte und einem
Arbeitsplatz der auch überwacht wird das
gibt es ja und das finde ich auch
richtig so aber ich denke dass das
einfach schwierig ist gerade bei dem
Thema natürlich ist macht auch nicht
jede Frau freiwillig da passiert viel an
der Grenze zu dem was wirklich schon
menschenhandel ist und auch tatsächlich
menschenhandel ist aber ich finde wir
müssen für alle Frauen egal ob sie es
freiwillig oder nicht freiwillig machen
dafür sorgen dass es ein sicherer Beruf
ist ja das betrifft ganz besonders die
Frauen die eben in diesem ungeschützten
und schwer kontrollierbaren Bereich der
Prostitution arbeiten müssen ansonsten
wird es noch leichter für Mörder und
perverse da ihr Unwesen zu treiben und
ganz ehrlich das kann uns doch nicht
egal sein auf jeden Fall ein Thema was
nicht mit diesem Fall endet aber wir
machen jetzt hier erstmal einen Punkt
wir haben den Fall erzählt mit Artikeln
aus The Guardian the independent und der
Daily Mail
Aufnahme und schnitt Toni Heyer Script
Stefan Netzeband Postproduktion weight
watch Studios München bis zum nächsten
mal eure Toni und euer Mirko